au fond est-ce que vous avez été sages
oui et bien bravo et c'est tout oui en
fait j'ai pas de cadeaux parce que parce
que tout le monde a été très sage cette
année c'est pas facile ou plus le fait
que je me suis pris un petit peu tard du
coup je distribue des petits mots
ok bah merci et bravo je vous ai dis
bravo au fait oui oh oh oh
est-ce que vous avez été sages oui j'ai
pas de cadeau vous êtes sûr que vous
m'avez bien envoyer votre petite liste
ouais je vous ai fait un mail à lens est
impossible parce que je lie to me veil à
regarder dans vos spams peut-être les
hommes l'espion mois dont 12 femmes
c'est vous rejoins tout de suite une
petite coquine dans ta région
non et bien dense j'ai un petit truc à
faire en fait d'accord mais et mes
cadeaux est-ce que vous avez été sages
non mais j'y crois pas tous vos trucs là
la magie de noël tout ça court c'est la
magie du marketing plutôt dans ça sert
juste à vendre des produits noël non on
est d'accord
pas du tout ah ouais les produits et
nous louis non on vend pas des produits
nous avons on vend des services les
assurances habitation plus exactement et
en ce moment il ya moins 30% pendant
toute la période de fêtes à des
assurances habitation exactement ah bah
ouais je suis chaud pourront souscrire
une alors c'est vrai nom allait barrez
vous allez aux eaux est-ce que vous avez
été sages oui et bien en ce qui a trait
aux plats alors premièrement vous êtes
censé le savoir je vais pas vous
l'apprendre les cadeaux ça se place sous
le sapin mais ça ne se jette pas comme
vous venez de le faire à l'instant
deuxièmement vous êtes censé arriver par
la cheminée qui est juste là et pas par
la chambre c'est quoi une chambre la
derby ça ça n'a pas de sens ça et pour
finir on est le 27 décembre
vous avez deux jours de retard sur la
livraison michel rougis agents de
l'inspection du travail
merde il en règle à le petit lutin des
coûts montrez-moi son contrat il est
parti là je me connais pas je les
gentils vous le connaissez pas c'est
arrivé à 2 arrivé tout seul c'est quoi
son nom lutte mis à la place de lutte a
commencé avec bonne journée oh oh oh
est-ce que vous avez été sages oui et il
me semble que vous aussi
du coup j'ai ça pour vous quoi mais
c'est la première fois qu'on en sera un
cadeau au mof jamais rien comme moi en
fait c'est le cadeau que vous m'avez
amenée l'année précédente
je n'aime pas en fait c'est la merde
aime pas voilà donc joyeux noël moi j'ai
rien vous avez été sages vous aussi chez
ça pour vous allez casser web os est ce
que vous avez été ça oui attendez mais
vous n'avez pas été créée par coca vous
j'étais sous contrat avec eux mais ça
c'était un long temps maintenant c'est
fini je peux avoir ce que je veux et
pepsi c'est vachement bon en fait
d'accord vous êtes sous contrat avec
pepsi c'est ça
oui vous m'avez appelé n'en oublie moi
cool quand ce plus de blé
hobo est ce que vous avez été sages oui
vous fêter noël tout seul oui je suis
orphelin en fait j'ai jamais eu la
chance de connaître mes parents j'avais
fait par votre avant bras
de quoi là là le bras droit là ça c'est
une tache de naissance à oui c'est une
tache de naissance que j'ai toujours
rire oui papa
toi moi c'est moi à l'année prochaine ça
ne m'a pas est-ce que vous avez été
sages un oui non je parlais pas voulu
parler aux gens qui regardent la vidéo à
part donc comme vous avez été sages on
vous offre un abonnement multi prises il
suffit de cliquer sur macarons vous vous
êtes pas foulé parce que ce cadeau en
fait il est gratuit toute l'année quoi
qu'est ce que vous avez dit vous vous
êtes pas foulé vous n'avez pas un
opposition à la lavette genre vous
m'entendez pas un sonotone est pas fou
votre cadeau attend pas